our subject for today i do solemnly
swear
decide what did i say
all right
and god speak all these words saying
i am the law thy god
which have brought thee out of the land
of egypt
out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any
grievan image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them
for i the lord thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
and showing mercy unto thousands of them
that love me
and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord
thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son
nor thy daughter
thy manservant nor thy midservant nor
thy cattle nor thy stranger that is
within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day and hallowed it
honour thy father
and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery
thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant
nor his maidservant
nor his ox nor his ass
nor anything
that is thy neighbors
god is good
come on god is good and all the time
psalm 100 verse 1
for the lord is good
his mercy is everlasting
and his truth endureth
finish it for me
to all generations forever
i welcome you to the house of god
to worship god in spirit
and in truth
jesus said god is a spirit
and they that worship him
must worship him
in spirit and in truth
john 4 24 spirit is not noise
spirit is simply that conformity to thus
saith the lord by the way the spirit is
called the spirit of truth
there are some who presume to worship in
spirit but not in truth you must have
both spirit and
truth
anything other than that and god cannot
accept it any more than he accepted
aaron's service when they worshipped
that golden calf he rejected it
absolutely it was not based on truth
may lord give us an increasing love
for plain and simple truth why
sanctify them through thy truth
thy word is truth
john 17 17
first thessalonians 4 verse
this is the will of god even your
sanctification
it is god's will you and i be sanctified
the method of sanctification
is the word of god and the word of god
is truth
last night i met two persons who were
not 70 adventists is the anyone present
this morning for the first time this
weekend you are not a seventh-day
adventist to make your hand
first time this weekend you are not a
seventh-day adventist may i see your
hand anyone
no one all right
may i offer a
unsolicited
suggestion anytime you meet whenever
possible
except for board meeting and church and
business meeting
invite someone if you can perhaps you
don't have the ready access
where you are in this place but whenever
you can
invite someone an invitation is a
soul-winning strategy and it requires no
special gifts talents or academic
degrees let me tell you a quick story
then i'll jump into the message
i was in uganda
long time ago
to conduct an evangelistic series i was
in the lobby of the hotel where i was
staying and i saw a young lady i began
talking to her
and she told me she was in the army she
was guarding a diplomat from another
country the diplomat was in her room
she was on break and a fellow
soldier was guarding the diplomat then i
told her why i was in uganda and i told
her i want you to come to the meetings
she said i'll come but i have no
and so i said a car will pick me up at 5
30. if you are ready in the lobby we'll
take you she was ready that was the
first night we took her she came she
came
every single night that's about 2002 20
years ago what do you think happened at
the end of the crusade
she got baptized
because someone issued a plain and
simple
invitation
i still communicate with her by whatsapp
she lives in germany now
still
faithful to god
an invitation i was in uganda not uganda
tanzania the very next year same purpose
evangelistic series and i was looking
for a gym so i can work out
and the local elder was with me and i
told him to tell the young lady the
receptionist why i was in her country
and i want her to come
again that was the first day of the
crusade she said i'll come she came that
first night
she came every night finished the story
she got baptized
invitations are powerful soul winning
tools instead of inviting your friend to
get into trouble invite your friend to
come to church with you and to listen to
the word of god somebody say amen
a lot of people are in graveyards
because a friend invited them to do
something
a lot of people are in drug
rehabilitation programs because a friend
invited them to do something a lot of
people are in prison because a friend
invited them to do something let it be
said that a lot of people will be in
god's kingdom because students at oha
invited their friends to come hear the
word of god can you say amen
all right enough of that our subject for
today i do solemnly swear
decide what did i say
all right
before i get into the message if you
don't need one of these as a bible text
please make sure it's turned off let me
check mine i have to put this down
off
make sure yours are off as well if you
don't need them
let me tell you another story i was in
boston several years ago i'm not a story
man but this came to me
it was a camp meeting held in a hotel
you worked that out yourself
and uh i was in my room waiting for my
turn to speak and i was in my room
literally pacing up and down reading the
bible on the phone
and at the bottom of the phone these
little apps appear am i right are these
advertisements you see them
this one here's a preacher reading the
bible getting ready to preach and an
advertisement came on the bottom
how to date asian women
all i needed to do was to take one of
these ten fingers
and tap it
and a gallery of faces would have popped
up
this can never happen with this
uh is this mic working
that can never happen with this are you
following me now when you turn to your
phones and phones have a legitimate
purpose in society
what is also on the phone beside the
text of the bible
whatsapp am i right instagram am i right
email am i right skype am i right you
name them snapchat come on you name them
you know them some of them they may be
your middle name come on tell me what
they are you know what they are so that
a temptation exists
once you open this to go look at your
picture gallery and look at the
boyfriend you took from your best friend
are you following me
these temptations do not exist with this
when you open this what you have thus
saith the lord and what else nothing
else
so i'm old-fashioned wherever possible
get one of these
and use this
if you need a calculator all right
seven number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter one verse nine then the
lord put forth his hand and touched my
mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and i want to
speak
god's words
faith number two three think as you
listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together here's an example that
god gives us jeremiah chapter 12 5 if
thou has run with the foot men come on
you know that verse
and they have what
where is the how then can thou contend
with the horses what is god saying think
use your head if you cannot keep up with
a man how do you plan to keep up with
the horse god calls upon us to think
i've been dating this young man for six
months
in those six months i fight more with my
parents
my bible study has gone down
my grades have gone down
i no longer go to church something is
wrong
think
get rid of him
are you listening to me or her
i joined the gym trying to lose weight
after three months i'm 30 pounds heavier
something is wrong
think
let's pray
our father in heaven we thank you for
the gift of life
thank you today god for this high honor
of speaking for you it is a privilege
angels would love to exercise
but you've given it to sinners such as i
i'm grateful to god
if you help me father i'll do all i can
to represent the truth alright
speak through me there father
let the spirit give me impressions
put your words in my mouth
and the humility of christ in my heart
bless everyone listening to god
speak to them individually father and if
someone did not identify himself or
herself as a guest a non-sda give a
special blessing to that person remember
your people in ukraine father i pray
from members of the household of faith
first be merciful to them and for the
country at large
bless the government of this country to
god remind them that righteousness
exalteth a nation bless oha in
everything this institution does that
this institution may prepare many for
the soon return of christ
bless the students their god you love
them so much young
strong full of energy use them for the
advancement of the gospel their god and
bless their families in jesus name i
pray
amen
what's your subject this side
too slow that side
i solemnly swear i do solemnly swear
in article
two
section
one
clause
eight
of the united states constitution
we have these words
i do solemnly swear
or affirm
that i will faithfully execute the
office
of president of the united states and
will to the best of my ability
preserve
protect
and defend the constitution of the
united states that is the presidential
oath and the wording is actually in the
constitution of the united states
so he can't choose or she his or her own
wording it is prescribed it is laid out
i do solemnly swear or affirm
that i will faithfully
execute the office of president of the
united states and will to the best of my
ability
preserve protect and defend
the constitution
of the united states
this country
is foundation stone of its activity is
the constitution
any law that is
unconstitutional is supposed to be
gotten rid of
everything must be in accordance with
the constitution i suspect every nation
has a constitution when some people
conduct a coup and they overthrow a
legitimate government they immediately
suspend the constitution of that country
in order that they might exercise
tyrannical rule the constitution is the
guide
for any nation particularly this nation
of ours the united states every country
every government
has a constitution
let me say it again
every government
has a constitution
including
the government of god
including the government of god
in patriarchs and prophets page 49
paragraph one
i hope you'll write these references
down patriarchs and prophets page 49
paragraph 1
god placed man under law
as an
indispensable condition of his very
existence
he was a subject of the divine
government and there can be no
government without law
law and government are inseparable there
can be no government in heaven or earth
without law and the law of god is the
constitution of the government of god
the law of god is the foundation of
god's government
in heaven
it is also the foundation of god's
government on earth
say the lord spray with me
our father
which art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come now carefully and
microscopically thy will be done in
earth come on as it is in heaven what is
the will of god the will of god is the
law of god
and jesus said
god's governmental foundation stone must
be the foundation stone for his kingdom
on earth
the ten commandments
which represent the standard of conduct
in heaven
that's the same standard god requires of
us on this earth so that the government
of god should be represented by his
believers on this earth
hawaii is one of the 50 states but it is
hundreds and hundreds of miles removed
from the contiguous 48 states alaska is
part of the united states hundreds of
miles removed from the 48 contiguous
states
what makes alaska part of the united
what makes hawaii part of the united
states is what
the constitution
they function by the same constitution
regardless of the distance
that alaska is for united states because
of canada and hawaii because of the
pacific ocean
this earth
is one of the states of heaven
eloy says
god created the world to enlarge heaven
let me say it again
god
ukraine is under invasion
by the russian army
and if russia succeeds
ukraine will become finish my words
a part of russia a few years ago russia
invaded the southern part of ukraine i
believe it is and took over an area
called what
the crimea that is now part of russia
are you following me when god made this
earth he made it to be an extension of
heaven so that all the stanzas of heaven
would apply to this earth we know sin
entered but god's standards do not
change you're saying to yourself why am
i saying that let us go to exodus 25 as
we continue i do solemnly swear
we recent verses with which you were
intimately familiar as seventh-day
adventists
exodus 25
we read from verse 8.
let me pray again father in heaven as i
continue tighten your grip on my
faculties i pray in jesus name
amen and let them make me a sanctuary
that i may dwell among them this is
always god's desire to dwell intimately
with his people no wonder jesus says and
if i go and prepare a place for you i
will come again and receive you where
unto myself because that is not the
relationship we have with christ on a
three dimensional basis yes through the
spirit he indwells us but we can't touch
him
that's not enough christ is coming back
so that where i am there he may be also
clearly we're not where he is
christ god believes in close
relationships
let them make me a sanctuary that i may
dwell among them verse 10
and they shall make an ark of him
wood
two cubes and a half shall be the length
thereof accurate and a half the breath
thereof and a cubit and a half the
height thereof
and thou shalt make what
and thou shalt ovulate with
pure gold without and within shalt thou
overlaid and shall make upon it a crown
of gold
round about
god is giving moses instructions for the
construction of his throne
verse 17
and thou shalt make a mercy seat of pure
gold
two cubits and a half shall be the
length thereof and a cupid and a half
the breath thereof
and thou shalt make two cherubims of
what gold of beaten work shall thou make
them in the two ends of the mercy seat
now
we have the box
which is the ark
we have the mercy seat the lid
we have two cherubims
and make one cherub on the one end
and the other cherub on the other end
even of the mercy seat shall we make the
cherubims on the two ends thereof verse
20 and the cherubim shall spread forth
their wings on high covering the mercy
seat with their wings and their faces
shall look one to another towards the
mercy seat shall the faces of the
cherubim be what is the bible telling us
the two angels were facing each other
but not looking at each other
they were looking down
what's down the mercy seat what's under
the mercy seat look at verse 21
and thou shalt put the mercy seat above
upon the ark and in the ark thou shalt
put the testimony that i shall give thee
what is the testimony tell me quickly
the ten commandments yes so we have the
box the lid and on the inside the ten
commandments
now
carefully and microscopically read verse
and there i will
meet with thee and i will commune with
thee from where
from above the mercy seat from between
the two cherubims which are on the ark
of the testimony finish that verse now
of
all things of what of all things which i
will give thee in commandment unto the
children of israel anything i say says
god it comes from right here
now where is right here
the throne of god
god is called he who sitteth between the
cherubims
go to psalm 99 quickly
psalm 99
let's read first one
our subject
i do solemnly swear
you have psalm 99
verse one
if you have my version read for me what
does that say the lord
reyneth come on
let the people tremble
keep reading now he
sitteth
ah yes let the earth be moved now those
two statements are virtually identical
the lord reigneth let the people tremble
he sitteth between the cherubims let the
earth be moved he reigns that's where
that's the place from which he reigns
between the cherubim that's his throne
a throne
now what is in the throne
the ten commandments
then what is the foundation of god's
government
the command the law
let me say it again the law of god
is the foundation of his universal
government for heaven and for earth
was the foundation stone of the united
states government the constitution god's
constitution
is his law
now
how is the united states quickly
identified particularly in foreign
countries
how do you know this u.s possession u.s
territory us whatever
the flag
you see no one sees the constitution
it's somewhere locked up somewhere you
don't see it it's not all over the place
in every supermarket you come to
everywhere you go you see
a flag
the flag
is the visual symbol of this nation
and in many schools people pledge
allegiance to the flag
and for
the country represents
god has a flag
for his government
is visual
it's open
it is seen
let's go look at that flag we took a
look at old glory the star and spangled
the star-spangled banner let's look at
god's flag
let us go to uh ezekiel 20.
what's our subject
i do solemnly swear
it's 11 56 i don't recall when i began
but please don't panic
ezekiel chapter 20 let's read verse 12.
have you found ezekiel
i can still hear pages turning
do we have it now
are my handsome brother still looking
oh go ahead it's
somebody help him
ezekiel chapter 20.
he may be little brother now 10 years
from now he may be conference president
you just don't know
now read that verse for me moreover also
i gave them my
sabbaths to be what a sign between
stop a sign between me and them not me
and the world
me and them but the world must recognize
it that they might know what that i am
the lord that doth sanctify them you
find similar words in ezekiel 20 20
exodus 31 12 13.
the flag of god's government
is the sabbath
are you with me
that flag is seen where god's sabbath
keepers are seen
let me say it again
god's government
has a flag
that flag
is the seventh day sabbath
the single most important of the ten
commandments
when the scribe came to christ in mark
chapter 12 28 and one of the scribes
came and having heard them reasoning
together and perceiving that he answered
them well asked him which is the first
commandment of all jesus answered him
the first of all the commandments is
hear o israel the lord our god is one
lord and thou shalt love the lord thy
god with all thy heart with all thy soul
but all thy mind with all thy strength
this is the first commandment and the
second is like namely this thou shalt
love thy neighbor as thyself now we know
that statement splits god's commandments
into two tables we know that
the first four love for god
the next six come on
love your fellow human being where does
the sabbath fall
on the first floor
now ellen white was taken in vision you
can read this in early writings jesus
showed her the ten commandments
she said
every one of them had a light
the first four had a brighter light than
the next six
because love for god must be greater
than love for a fellow man
he the lovely father and mother more
than me is not worthy of me the first
four had a brighter light than the next
six then she said
the sabbath was brightest of all and it
had a halo all around it
now those pictures of angels with halos
the sabbath had the brightest light it
had a halo the sabbath commandment is
the flag of god's government
and the constitution of god's government
is his law
now
the president of united states the
president-elect
he takes a vow
i do solemnly swear or affirm
that i will faithfully execute
the office of president of united states
and will to the best of my ability
preserve protect
and defend
the constitution of united states
do you know god's law is supposed to be
preserved
protected and defended
when god took adam and put him in a
garden to address it and to keep it the
word keep means protect treasure
defender
this is how we are to love the law of
god we are to preserve protect defend
not simply by what we say
but by
how we live
now god is calling upon you as citizens
of his kingdom because literally you and
i by virtue of surrendering our lives to
christ are literal sins citizens of the
kingdom of god
one one person said amen go to
philippians 3
quickly philippians 3.
do you have that
not yet
philippians 3 let's read from verse 20
our subject i do solemnly swear
do you have it now
read loud with me
for our conversation is where
stop the translation of conversation
there is citizenship
listen to me carefully
if you are a child of god
your first level of identification is
not a us citizen it is a citizen of the
kingdom of god
every other level of identification
falls second third or fourth
if that's not the case you'll find
yourself defending earthly governments
above the government of god
you are first and foremost a child of
god's kingdom that's why jesus told
pilate my kingdom is not of this world
if my kingdom were of this world then
would my servants fight
that i should not be delivered to the
jews but now is my kingdom not from
hence he told pilate because my
disciples are citizens of the heavenly
kingdom they don't fight
you are a citizen of god's kingdom
and god wants you
to preserve
protect
and defend the constitution of his
kingdom what is that constitution the
law of god now let me show you what
christ came to do go to romans chapter
8.
romans 8 let's read from verse 1. our
subject
i do solemnly swear
three minutes after 12.
you have romans 8
father in heaven as i continue continue
to pour out your spirit upon me for your
glory day god and for the blessing of
your people in jesus name i pray amen
read with me
there is therefore now no condemnation
to them which are in christ jesus who
walk not after the flesh but after the
spirit for the law of the spirit of life
in christ jesus hath made me free from
the law of sin and death for what the
law could not do in that it was weak
through the flesh god sending his own
son in the likeness of sinful flesh and
for sin condemned sin in the flesh read
verse 4
that the righteousness of the law come
on might be fulfilled where in us who
walked not after the flesh but after the
spirit jesus christ when he came he
preserved he protected and he defended
the law of god
think not
that i am come to destroy the law or the
prophets i am not come to destroy
tell me the words but to fulfill
jesus christ by his love he exampled he
displayed that you and i through faith
in him can preserve protect and defend
the law of god
do you understand the seventh-day
adventists the issue in the last days it
has always been but particularly the
last day
is the law of god
when the sunday law is passed
and those who choose it will have the
mark of the beast
those who oppose it will come under
fierce persecution
how will you choose
will you be able to say
i will to the best of my ability
preserve
protect
and defend the constitution of united
states and based on the sunday law i
pres i will preserve protect and defend
the sabbath commandment not by fighting
the government but by obeying god
god let me give an example of someone
who did not use the word swear or affirm
but it amounted to the same thing go to
ruth chapter 1.
ruth chapter 1 we read from verse 14 our
subject i do solemnly swear
you have ruth
chapter one ruth is a ancestor of jesus
christ
a more bitus
a country that practiced a terrible form
of religion
but yet christ had a relative from that
country
if you study the genealogy of christ you
can take hope if you're a very bad
person or whatever you may be christ has
some shaky people in his line
but he can save any who come to him do
you have ruth chapter four one reading
from verse 14
and they lifted up their voice and wept
again
and opera kiss her mother-in-law but cle
but ruth clave unto her
naomi was about to go back to her home
country palestine
and she was in moab for about 10 years
because there was a famine in her home
now she's going back her two sons have
died she has two daughters in law who
are widows now
and one daughter-in-law orpah decides to
stay i'm going back stay where i am i'm
familiar my own people
ruth made it evident she wants to follow
naomi
and she said behold
thy daughter-in-law is gone back unto
her people and unto her gods return thou
after thy sister-in-law
and ruth said now read with me now this
is equal to i do solemnly swear and
affirm listen to ruth read with me and
ruth said what entreat me not to leave
thee or to return from following after
thee for wither thou goes come on i will
go without largest i will lodge thy
people shall be my people and thy god my
god where thou diest will i die and
there will i be buried the lord do so to
me and more finish that verse if ought
but death part thee from me only death
can keep me from following you
listen to verse 18.
read it for me
when she saw
that she was
steadfastly minded to the world to go
with her finish the verse she left
speaking unto her
let's apply that to the devil as we
continue i do solemnly swear
many times the devil keeps coming to us
because he gets success
you see
when he tempted christ three times the
bible says he left him for a while he
was probably exhausted because christ
just hit him over the head with the
bible it is written it is written so he
took off to catch his breath
we must let the devil see
that he's wasting time
naomi realized i am wasting time talking
to ruth
why because ruth in a very practical
sense had solemnly sworn
i am following you
where you go
i'm going
the hotel you book into i'm booking into
the god you worship i'll worship the
people you claim as your own i'll came
as my own where you die i'll die
where you're buried i want to be buried
now how do you stop a person like that
now
jesus wants you and me to say
where you send me
i'll go
what you tell me to speak
i'll speak what you tell me to eat
i'll eat how you tell me to dress i'll
dress how you tell me to spend my money
i'll spend it when you tell me how to
conduct a romantic relationship i'll do
that only death can stop me
when this is the mindset satan goes
after someone he has greater success
with
because a person like that gives the
devil a migraine
he doesn't know what to do
nothing i do will change that person
shadrach well let's give the hebrew
names hananiah mishael azariah nothing
nebuchadnezzar could do and he at that
point in his life personified the devil
the threat of death
and those three boys virtually said
we do solemnly swear
that we will preserve
protect and defend
the commandment that forbids worshipping
idols
daniel 6
allah was passed pray to darius daniel
virtually said i do solemnly swear i
will preserve protect defend the law
that says thou shalt have no other gods
before me i'll face the lions
the three boys i'll face death by fire
jesus christ if thou be willing remove
this cup from me nevertheless
not my will
i'm going to that cross
that's what god wants from you and me
i do solemnly swear
to the best of my ability
i will not take that exam on sabbath
i do solemnly swear that by the grace of
god when it comes to god and his law it
has to be by his grace by the grace i
will not work on sabbath i was many
years ago there was a retired minister
was assisting me i was running a little
church outside detroit and he was my
assistant retired minister lovely man
and he and i were talking one sabbath
afternoon after potluck and he said to
me said olskey many years ago as a young
man i was married two sons no job my
wife got jobs cleaning people's houses i
couldn't get a job that did not require
sabbath work and i determined not to
work on sabbath he said one day i was in
the house my wife was working cleaning
someone's house and i looked at my two
little boys just watching me
and he told me these words he said i
said to god
i will watch those two sons of mine
starved to death
before i work on sabbath
when he said that to me he was about 88
a strange strength came over him you see
him he pumped his arm i will watch them
starve to death
before i work on sabbath veins bulging
in his neck and i said man
this man is serious
there's nothing the devil can do with
him
i was told the story in the 1970s or the
80s after amin was thrown out in uganda
a fellow called milton oberti come came
back into rule and his soldiers would do
whatever they wanted to do they would
come from house to house abduc girls and
take them away or whatever else and i'll
take away people who are worshiping on
the sabbath and one night they came to a
house looking for adventists or
christians
any christians in this house said no
then the soldier said who lives next
door they said there's an old man
he's a christian yes he's an adventist
the soldier says okay let's go get him
the people said you're wasting your time
you're wasting time there is nothing you
can do to that old man to get him to
stop worshiping god
and the soldiers
just left him alone
went off to another house
it's not a funny story but i want to
stress they realize they would have to
shoot that old
man i'm keeping the sabbath
kill me but this is not strange down for
the years martyrs have said we do
solemnly swear
that we will preserve protect and defend
the pure gospel of jesus christ
and they went to the state
they burned they went to the roman er
was that coliseum eaten by lions
taken into dens by the inquisition and
torn in pieces
because they were determined
i will preserve
protect
and defend
the constitution of god's government
his law
let me tell you again that 12 13
there is soon to come upon this world
a situation that will require each of us
to say i do solemnly swear that i will
preserve protect defend the constitution
of god's government or i do unwillingly
agree to preserve protect and defend the
constitution of this country which will
include at that point a man-made sabbath
and you and i will have to choose
between obeying god
and obeying man acts 5 29 we ought to
obey
god rather than man
the bible never calls us to be
rebellious it calls us to be obedient
and sometimes frequently obedience to
god but all the time brings us into
conflict with the enemy of our souls
you are young
and young people are
brave and courageous and sometimes
fearless
should i give you this statistic
i was listening to a young man on
television
he had broken his legs
and he was saying why
i think he was door dashing or something
like that and there were some young men
in the house where he went they were
doing some silly stuff jumping off roofs
and whatever they do
and uh they asked him to do it
and where he jumped ah can you jump
higher from a higher height
and because there were several young
guys watching him he felt i had to do it
so he jumped from a higher height and
now had two broken legs
what am i saying are you
young people are willing to take risks
not because they're bad because they're
exploring the world
god says fine
take that risk for me
take that risk from me
if you lose your life you lose it for me
he that loseth his life for my sake
shall find it
but i'm not calling upon you to lose
your life i'm calling upon you to adopt
a frame of mind
that in all that you do and say you will
say in your heart
i do solemnly swear by the grace of god
that i will preserve
protect and defend the constitution of
god's government and what is that
constitution the law of god
in the judgment
let us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter fear god and keep his
commandments for this is the whole duty
of man for god shall bring every work
into judgment with every secret thing
the standard in the judgment is the law
of god
but let me tell you this before i close
before you accuse me of legalism
is jesus the bread yes or no yes is
jesus the shepherd yes or no
is he the vine
is he the door
is he the sheep
he's also the law
now you missed it my fault
jesus
is the law
question for you
where was the liver placed in the
sanctuary system where was the labor
the out of court was that holy
yes but it was as holy as the holy place
no
where was the table of shoe bread
was that holy
holy than the outer court
yes but as holy as the holy holiest no
where was the the uh the the seven
branch candelabrum the holy place
where's the altar vincent's the holy
place
all all the vincent's prayer the candle
abram the light of the word the the um
the shoe bread the word of god the liver
the water christ is the living water the
altar of sacrifice calvary
what was in the most holy place
the law
now think with me could not god have put
the law in the outer court
i'm all by myself
nobody's listening
could not god have put the law in the
outer court yes
he could have put it in the holy place
he put it in the most holy why because
the entire problem of sin has to do with
violation of god's law
and if the veil represents christ
if the alt of sacrifice represents
christ
if that shoe bread represents christ
if the instance represents christ if the
candelabrum represents christ surely
the law finish my words represents
christ eloise says christ with both the
law and the gospel so when you preserve
protect and defend the law you are
preserving protecting and defending the
very righteousness of christ
in colleges
they're organizations called
fraternities
and they have a satanic practice called
hazing
and people die
people die
from this hazing
god isn't haze
god just calls you to be a part of this
heavenly fraternity or sorority give
your life to me
and be willing to die
for me
this is not symbolic language be willing
literally to die for me to die rather
than sin
i solemnly swear
that i will to the best of my ability
preserve
protect
defend the constitution of god's
government
i do solemnly swear or affirm to the
best of my ability i will preserve
protect and defend the historical
teachings of this church
i do solemnly swear that by the grace of
god to the best of my ability i will
preserve protect defend everything oha
stands for
and by the grace of god
i do solemnly swear
that i will preserve
protect and defend others from any
negative influence i may exert
my brothers and sisters
god needs people
whose entire life
is a defense of his law
is a defense of righteousness
how many of you will say with me
by the grace of god
now it's not necessary for an earthly
government but for god's government by
the grace of god
to the best of my ability
i will preserve
protect defend the constitution of god's
government can i see your right hand
i believe you're serious stand up with
me
your age makes no difference
no difference at all
has bowed
eyes closed
our father in heaven
we thank you for your word
we thank you to god for the high
standard you've set for us it shows us
what a loving father you are because as
verily as earthly parents set high
standards for their children
you have set a high standard for us it
is your very character your very
righteousness that's why we're told in
the scriptures let this mind be in you
we're told to partake of your holiness
we're told that we may partake of the
divine nature
father
we are heavily citizens temporarily
stranded on this earth
we're pilgrims on our way home
but while we are temporarily stranded
there god
we ask you to give us the mind of christ
who preserved
protected
and defended with his life
the constitution of his father's
government
please god
give us that seriousness of mind
that intense devotion to you
that we might say in everything we do
and it might be seen without any verbal
communication that we are preserving
protecting and defending the
constitution of god's government and
that constitution is his law but
ultimately the law is christ
please god
give us an affection for your government
give us a love for your law as david
says in psalm 119 verse 97 oh how love i
thy law
let us understand the law is really
christ within
bless everyone who's listened to this
message
bless those with a particular struggle
in their lives their god we may look
sinless we may look like saints but we
all have private struggles help your
sons and your daughters their god grant
them victory over their struggles
and as we leave the surface let's
meditate
on what we've heard
let us remember
by the grace of god
to the best of our ability humanity
cooperating with divinity we will
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of god's govern
that constitution is his law and that
law is personified in jesus christ
himself
here it is humble pray father bless all
that we will do for the remainder of
this day let's do it in a way that
glorifies your name i pray for my heart
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen
[Music]
you